[Aplausos]
recordar que estaré muerto en poco
tiempo es la mejor herramienta que
encontrado para expandir un mensaje y
para tomar grandes decisiones
porque todo expectativas externas el
orgullo miedo al qué dirán o el fracaso
caen ante la muerte dejando a penas lo
que es importante
no hay razón para no dejar seguir tu
corazón
estos fueron una de las afirmaciones de
steve jobs cuando fue diagnosticado con
cáncer y me he preguntado si tenemos que
tener una noticia de estas para tomar
grandes decisiones
si tú supieras que te queda el último
tiempo de tu vida qué gran decisión
tomaría
ahora quiero que se imaginen una cosa
qué tal si esa gran decisión fuera
encontrar tu propósito pero no sólo esto
sino encontrar la forma y el canal para
expandir esto y hacer un impacto en el
mundo
hoy puedo decir que yo vivo de mi
propósito
y que he logrado encontrar en el digital
el mejor canal para expandir esto
e impactar a millones de personas en
latinoamérica
antes de contarte mi historia y como lo
logré
quiero que nos alineamos en el concepto
de propósito y canal digital
a propósito para mí no es un sueño es
diferente a los roles que tenemos como
seres humanos
quieren saber qué es propósito
bueno en mi visión propósito es esa gran
pregunta para que vine al mundo para que
viniste tú al mundo
acaso esta no sería una pregunta que
quisiéramos de primera respondernos o
acaso no sería esa pregunta que debería
ser el quiz de bachillerato
porque en mi experiencia esta es la
mayor realización que alguien puede
alcanzar
a propósito es la unión de tres cosas
primero pasión qué es lo que realmente
te apasiona qué es lo que hace arder tu
corazón todos aquí tenemos una historia
y tal vez no hemos pasado por una
frustración y por un proceso donde
encontramos una respuesta un camino
y ahí nace lo que arde en tu corazón
número 2 la habilidad tal vez en esa
experiencia ganas de habilidades que
nadie tiene como tú y normalmente es
esto que las personas te buscan
porque nadie lo hace mejor que tú
y número 3 que necesita el mundo
en el mundo hay personas que tal vez
están pasando por necesidades por una
dificultad y qué tal si tu pasión
combinado con tu habilidad es eso que el
mundo necesita
ahora
de qué vale encontrar tu propósito
si lo vas a dejar para ti y no lo vas a
expandir
en mi experiencia me di cuenta que el
propósito fue hecho para otros no fue
hecho para ti y por eso se convirtió en
una gran responsabilidad
y es tu responsabilidad
hoy con el canal
qué es el digital tú puedes llegar a
millones de personas e incluso personas
que tú no conoces y que están en otro
lado que tú nunca has ido pero con el
digital
tú puedes llegar a impactar a estas
personas que están buscando o esperando
de un mensaje de transformación que
venga de ti
ahora quiero contarles parte de mi
historia y como logré esto
vengo de una familia emprendedora y de
aquí nace mi pasión por el
emprendimiento a mis 18 años salgo de mi
casa pero no a otra casa salgo del país
pero no a cualquier otro país me fui al
otro lado del mundo me fui a australia
allá estudie mi carrera universitaria
y comencé a estudiar a trabajar al mismo
tiempo provee ese mundo laboral pero
siempre supe que quería emprender
a mis 24 años empecé un emprendimiento
en australia y vi que me apasionaba cómo
podía llegar a impactar personas con lo
que yo estaba haciendo día a día
pero quiero decirles que empezó a nacer
una insatisfacción porque yo veía
alrededor
en australia personas que tal vez habían
logrado la parte material y yo en cierta
forma tal vez tenía una vida a los 24
años que ustedes quisieran tener pero
saben cuando llegué en ese momento había
algo que mi corazón no hacía sentido y
empecé a preguntarle a las personas
alrededor y ellos me decían pues tú vas
a conseguir una ciudadanía australiana
para tener más oportunidades y yo sabía
mi corazón que eso no era lo que decía
ser mi propósito
entonces en el 2014 cuando me gradué mis
papás me regalaron un viaje a brasil me
fui allá con toda mi familia y como era
un viaje de dos meses decidido dejar
toda una casa en una bodega porque se
podrán imaginar lo que incluye una casa
sala comedor ropa todos los en una
bodega y en ese viaje de dos meses creo
que llegó el momento más crucial de mi
vida porque me encontraba en una gym o
me devolvía australia o me quedaba en
colombia que significaba para mí
volverme australia era seguir estudiando
para obtener una visa y tal vez tener
una buena vida pero por otro lado estaba
colombia
y en colombia aunque había incertidumbre
de lo que yo iba a ser realmente
sabía que yo podía emprender puedes
hacer que mi familia podría tal vez
cuidar de otras áreas que las tenía
descuidadas en australia
y comenzar ese emprendimiento que tanto
quería
y comenzar de cero y saben que escogí
quedarme en colombia
dejarme llevar por esa convicción porque
para tomar grandes decisiones tú tienes
que hacer grandes sacrificios y ese fue
mi sacrificio pero ese momento fue
difícil porque tenía la presión de tener
una carrera afuera el no saber qué hacer
y lo primero que dije voy a hacer ese
emprendimiento que estaba haciendo en
australia
ese era mi mejor decisión en ese momento
hasta que un día sentada en el comedor
de mi casa con mi hermano frente a
frente él me preguntó laura
qué es lo que a ti realmente te hace
feliz
y para mí en ese momento fue pues este
emprendimiento y le di mis razones de
por qué eso era lo que me hacía feliz y
me dice te puedo decir una cosa
yo sí claro
me dice
yo creo que lo que tú me estás diciendo
que te hace feliz realmente en el fondo
de tu corazón tú sabes que esto no es lo
que te hace feliz
en este momento yo quedé pasmada la
verdad se me ahogaron los ojos
y sentí que me quito el suelo porque esa
respuesta era la respuesta asegura que
yo tenía
pero muy el fondo en mi corazón sabía
que eso no era lo que me hacía feliz
después vino una peor pregunta y me dice
que pasa así la vida dios te tiene para
vivir debajo de un puente allí empecé a
llorar porque no le veía razón a esa
pregunta y saben que hice en ese momento
me fui debajo de un puente mentiras me
fui a un parque me fui a un parque sola
con una hoja y un espejo
y empecé a notar todo lo que tal vez él
me había confrontado y quería buscarle
las respuestas a sus preguntas
empecé a notar que me hacía feliz empecé
a escribir que era importante para mí y
yo había escuchado que para saber hacia
dónde queremos ir
tenemos que saber quiénes somos y
incluso anote en esas hojas mis valores
porque quería encontrarme y tal vez
personas que veían desde afuera una
mujer con una carrera en el exterior
perdida en un parque yo en ese momento
me estaba era encontrando
después a los bueno en ese momento yo me
hice dos preguntas que tal vez ustedes
hoy se las pueden hacer
porque en ese parque no encontré la
respuesta de qué es un propósito o cuál
era mi propósito pero si encontré una
respuesta que recuerdo llegando a mi
casa en la noche diciéndole mami mira lo
que encontré y era que yo tenía que
comenzar en el proceso para alcanzar ese
propósito porque tú puedes tener las
mejores herramientas tu puedes incluso
tener una idea de qué es su propósito
pero si tú no estás preparado no vas a
hacer nada con eso entonces las dos
preguntas que me hice fue cuáles son mis
convicciones
en este momento y qué es lo mejor que
tengo en mis manos para comenzar hoy
mis convicciones eran no quería emplear
me yo quería ser emprendedora
y lo mejor que tenía en ese momento para
comenzar era un conocimiento que había
adquirido en la universidad mi hermano
que sabía hacer páginas web y bueno nada
inversión porque cuando vi
en mi cuenta no había nada de dinero
incluso yo me había venido con una deuda
de australia
mi hermano me prestó para esa inversión
inicial y comencé mi emprendimiento y
ese primer emprendimiento pago esas
deudas pago esa inversión inicial pero
también me dejó mucho porque empecé a
descubrir lo que me apasiona hoy lo que
no y me empezó a direccionar a los dos
años llegó esa visión y ese propósito
que hoy llamo proyecto de vida yo hoy
tengo una misión y es
ser canal de expansión
para aquellas personas que tienen un
mensaje de transformación y no saben
cómo expandir eso y por eso soy
apasionada por la tecnología digital
porque encontrado que ese es el mejor
canal para tu poder llegar más lejos
para tu poder llegar a hacer un gran
impacto en el mundo
el canal digital no lo tienes que ver
como el monstruo de siete cabezas la
verdad es que es el mejor canal para
expandir lo que tú eres crees y haces
ahora ustedes estarán diciendo pero yo
no sé nada de esto aquí les vengo a
mostrar como en la práctica ustedes
están
a nada
de poder empezar a difundir un mensaje
de transformación quiero que todos
saquen aquí su celular
quiero que lo hacen y lo miren por dos
segundos
este
lo que ustedes tienen en sus manos todos
los días
es la mejor herramienta que ustedes
pueden usar para comenzar
a difundir ese mensaje que hay dentro de
ustedes
no hay excusas esto realmente es una
responsabilidad que ustedes tienen el
digital lo pueden usar como distractor o
lo pueden usar como una herramienta
perfecta para llegarle a millones de
personas
por eso quiero terminar con esto
usted es cada uno de ustedes tiene un
propósito
y eso los hace como canales
transformadores
eso es una gran responsabilidad que
ustedes tienen hoy
pero también será la mayor realización
que ustedes podrán realizar
porque si tú
dejas tu luz brillará dejas que las de
otros brillen
[Aplausos]